toxic and fear are definitely two words
that I would associate with offset
inspections and the toll they take is
being likened to a mental health crisis
for teachers it used to make me feel
like physically sick I was absolutely
petrified Jane left the profession
partly because of it she describes a
Culture of Fear I had a really awful
awful inspection after that I couldn't I
had a panic attack every time I needed
even an informal observation in my
teaching and I just I couldn't do it
anymore a rising number are speaking out
after head teacher Ruth Perry took her
own life following an inspection I lost
my little sister Ruth 15 weeks and six
days ago her sister addressing the union
conference
urged reform when three ofsted
inspectors pronounced on frankly flimsy
grounds that Ruth's leadership and
therefore her school were inadequate
the Injustice of that one word judgment
destroyed Ruth's career her world and
her sense of self
ofsted defended the inspection saying
there's no reason to doubt it and have
refused to drop one word assessments
because they're easier for parents to
understand what the teaching profession
on the unions and the head teachers in
particular aren't saying is that they
are very happy
to boast about their ofsted ratings on
their websites and on their notice
boards outside their schools nor are
they saying that 88 of schools are
either rated good or outstanding so if
often has a fault it is is too generous
and too kind parents at this fourth
birthday party have just chosen primary
schools for September relying on ofsted
reports it's the only way that you can
as a first-time parent with a child
going into a school understand how the
school is what the reputation is and
what their importances are I think it
does need some work and I think it needs
looking at how
as how they can support the the parents
the children and the staff I think needs
to obviously continue to be updated and
reviewed and make sure it's relevant and
everything else but the whole principle
of them absolutely um I'm all for them
[Applause]
to agree reform may be needed a
reflection on the pressure of
inspections amid criticism they offer
merely a snapshot Adele Robinson Sky
News